another huge primary night in america
with possible implications for the
midterms progressive candidates having a
rough go at it in new york impeachment
lawyer dan goldman ousted far left
representative monder jones the guy who
gets democrats elected sean patrick
maloney won his primary over an aoc
backed challenger and florida voters
picking former republican now democrat
charlie crist over a progressive to face
governor ron desantis this fall
but the most delicious highlight of the
night was this bitter feud between two
sitting democratic house lawmakers
career politician jerry nadler cruised
to victory ending congresswoman carolyn
maloney's 30-year run in congress
maloney lobbing claims of sexism over
her bruising loss
women fought sexist systems and misogyny
that continues today as we know from my
own campaign
i'm really saddened that we no longer
have a woman representing manhattan in
congress
bringing
and we cannot and we must not give up
the fight continues
all right dana she got walloped she did
uh there was a redistricting that pitted
to
you know of the liberal lions in the
house and adler and maloney but for her
claiming you know misogyny and all that
isn't that kind of an old song and
well remember they've been in congress
since 1993 two ninety nine two yeah so
they've been there they've been serving
together the democrats have completely
screwed up redistricting in new york and
that's why you see these results so then
you have carol and maloney and now
they're have to um fight against each
other and the ads got really nasty and
i'm kind of sad it's over because it's
kind of fun to watch like you're seeing
nia well you're sexist
and they're having this big fight then
there was a third person siraj patel who
tried to play spoiler but now there i
think partly because he was so visible
during the
trump impeachments that the liberals of
new york city said that's going to be
our guy i also think it's interesting
that mondaire jones lost because that's
a member of the squad
and now there's they're down one and you
know who's probably celebrating today
abigail spamberger
you know when you talk about the squad
that the progressives and i'll go to you
on this uh harold the progressives did
not have a great night whether uh it was
the aoc backed the candidate biaggi
uh or the one that she wanted supported
quaalar against his narrows
the aoc backed candidates did not do
well
and max rose won against a progressive
as well what does that tell us looking
at the midterms dems are more moderate
the national message for dims they
understand to be successful they're
gonna that you have to distance yourself
from dysfunction and be more aligned
with progress and more aligned with uh
outcomes serious outcomes for people to
the biggest race i thought in the state
last night was the bellwether state
where
democrat pat ryan beat a very popular i
believe he told a fellow named mark
molinaro
is a two-point race
in abortion and freedom right freedom of
women's freedom and women's choice
played a huge role in that race so again
we talked about polls the other day on
the show no poll right now is is
decisive or conclusive it's instructive
but i'll tell you this these are actual
numbers with actual voters voting
democrats should be pleased with last
night and the country should too because
if democrats get back to the middle we
have a fighting chance not only as a
party but i think it's a country to get
things done and then two democrats want
a key key district here in new york you
know jesse they talk about the decision
the dobbs decision uh you know not
really affecting that many people but i
think that the one race that harold just
referenced and that's the marc molinaro
uh uh race and pat ryan race uh that was
pretty much all on abortion and molinero
was a very popular guy
uh
should the republicans be concerned
about this now
i am concerned about it so they should
be concerned about it
yeah i'm a little concerned
[Applause]
[Laughter]
is this the best we have this crop of
candidates you look at someone like
nadler who looks like a hobbit he's
representing the richest district in the
entire country but he is that the best
we can do
right that's what i'm saying like no one
else wants to run for congress on the
upper east side or the upper west side i
live on the upper east side i see
beautiful people walking around tall
healthy all of their hair they're quick
with wit and they know what they're
talking about the guy looks like he's
not going to make it to the next session
he's the best we can do
and then
the woman uh maloney she's having
someone else hold the microphone up and
she's just saying everything's sexist
yeah the people in the upper west side
and the upper west side
are not sexist they just think you stink
like this is this is who we have
representing us okay i'm gonna go uh to
tyrus right now oh yeah i'm excited to
follow that all right
shake what you got now you know
biden can say look i got the inflation
reduction act passed which has nothing
to do with inflation reduction but who
cares and you know i got the senate to
vote for finland and nato to be part uh
finland and sweden to be part of nato
and semiconductor and burn pits and i'm
thrilled even mitch mcconnell isn't that
excited about winning the senate uh
are the democrats better positioned than
a lot of people thought they were you
know i would like to say yes but
unfortunately president biden who used
to be a moderate monster and i was
actually too strict on things like crime
and etc he beat the progressives become
president but he laid down like a
folding chair for them and he's been
their puppet ever since so it's nice to
see it's not about the politicians the
american people spoke and i'm happy to
see as a republican real democrats stand
up and this progressive first world
problem stuff where your pronoun is the
biggest argument that's going on in your
kitchen table is taking a backseat to
real issues and i'm happy to see
democrats where have you been welcome
back to the table like but like just
seem a little uncomfortable but i'd
rather be in that argument with somebody
i can have a dialogue with where as soon
as i open my mouth like misogynistic and
if i say something else you're a racist
you know and yeah you know it's a little
rough being a white supremacist these
days disappointing disappointing that
maloney went out like that oh it was it
was misogyny you know 32 years
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else